non ci credo giusto in tempo il menù di
spalla sparisce tornata del nuovo gioco
di credito no non ci abbiamo mai giocato
prima volta che giochiamo alla fine del
video date un voto a questo gioco da una
difesa anche noi ci siamo il nostro solo
tazza che sia molto moro non è che
secondo me po di novità fate un bel mi
piace qui sotto se questo video
antichissimi amica se ci sarà un altro
video con premi
mettetevi con i preti pop corn e
iniziamo créme 3 ok andiamo facciamo
facile sì perché alle borse di cheese
procederemo un sacco di monte
bisogna scegliere se mettere g g
entrambi mettiamo in entrata che succede
a 63 il milione
no questa è la sua casa penso l'entrata
il cancello
c'è una camera si sta spiando ma che
bella la casa era così anche prima
no affatto chiuso corporatura nuova casa
più grande
ma ciò non è molto rassicurante questa
casa c'è i coccodrilli dentro con
l'acqua e vengo in corno da casa è
infatti attirato sul ponte bene non
possiamo vischio appare adesso una
macchina distrutta diamo il nonno
ma facciamo un verso non sono uno che
chi ci siamo svegliati notiamo invece
per il 9 quindi il nonno c'è ha
catturato e ci ha messo in prigione volo
poi in casa lui chiave forse c'è
qualcosa di più è uno di quegli attrezzi
per aprire le porte ok se volete
televisivi da vi pare bisogna aprire la
porta così tenendo premuto però potrebbe
arrivare se sente dei rumori e si aiuto
aperto la porta per fortuna lo sprinter
cosa ci faceva qua la famiglia di
grannies la ndrina apparsa
all'improvviso
iniziamo bene dobbiamo tenere a mente o
un tacco in questo gioco
a questo va aperto anche con questo ecco
ci sia uno scheletro l'ho dentro a chi
non lo so negli scorsi giocatori mamma
mia
ad resterebbe in a letto ci sono delle
scale una porta che non mi va benissimo
comunque la casa si erano gioco c'è
qualcosa dice questo ma non a casa così
cosa andavamo così i denti ho come
l'impressione pietro ricci la mamma poi
per fortuna abbiamo certo facile da di
sé sistri ndrine legge non c'è da
spendere ancora questa volta dobbiamo
aperta prima giusto ok forse per chi non
fosse una cosa sia di mezzo i maschi
blog è stata meta appunto per farti
prendere degli inferi con dovessi qui
c'è qualcosa picchiata no si vuole la
testa
siamo neanche riusciti a salire
eliminato così ci crede morti 4 e allora
adesso dobbiamo andare veloci secondo me
perché se nostri ma qui all'improvviso
il corri ci compare allora ci fa venire
un sacco di ante un grave stefano rosi
di graham i e ii davvero l'ora qui ci
sono dei proiettili ho visto la prima
dobbiamo assemblare l'arma immagina
siamo usciti bene grazie ad esso però
che c'è qualcuno che ce ne sono il nonno
ma non riusciamo a scappare perché siamo
così lenti ha fatto tranquillante vice
ha colpito che cosa c è bloccato da da
un lucchetto però questo questo capanno
degli attrezzi
quindi dobbiamo trovare una mia me c'è
qualcosa che a sberluccicante la chiave
che cosa che non possiamo non me lo può
selezionare dobbiamo selezionare
se ci ha preso una volta il nonno una
volta che rende due volte rendere
ritorno gianfranco è l'ultimo giorno dai
che non è adatta a noi abbiamo la pietra
ma che possiamo fare con la pietra
l'altro non si sa proviamo esplorare la
parte di sopra
prima che arrivino il nonno la nonna
oltre ndrina chi altro se sono già devo
veloce non vi fermerete non mi fermo qui
ridenti io mi sono nascosto non ci credo
giusto il tempo
bravo che ti sei nascosto subito e
perché l'ho sentito comunque è anche
molto migliore grafica si supera bene è
stato un patto preso bene poi giocare a
nascondino
no grazie saranno non so se uscirà
brothers da e non tornerà subito qua
invece mi sono un sacco di cose da
esplorare in questa casa parla lei è
andata di larmes abbiamo sopra allora
via pian piano grazie allora qui sembra
ok andiamo a vedere che c'è in questa
volta
cos'è questo il bar questa casa di maio
dobbiamo vecchio prodotto la musica non
è dio ma non nasconde racconto io ho
paura che arrivi nei fatti non amo le
reti arrivano tutte le trans che ti
conviene nascondere quanto io che cosa
c'è qui ma perché in modo così te
l'avevo detto non devi fare il rumore
questo gioco altrimenti arriva d'orlando
l'amore che cosa c'è più da mangiare
solo cibi per stare al timone a
trattandosi cos'è mi nascondo qui sono
caduto
non sono un passaggio segreto tipo un
ascensore solo ti manca la cia il sole
siamo intrappolati qui dentro si è
tornato riuscito forse in cui cina cosa
prendete una padella e da una padella di
festa no non c'è niente ma non sono
niente in cucina questi sono riuscito a
scappare sono riuscito a scappare perché
bisogna muoversi veloce con no no no no
nessuno è la musica che verrà posta
sopra siamo già saliti a questo ma
sappiamo
ci ha messo in macchina treni che brutta
il nome di la vite ma sta cercando
subito anche l'ora
certo sono un po tonto che riproviamo ma
con la modalità pratica fantasma così
non c'è né no non è la nonna red line ii
raduno potremo esplorare la cara stata
c'è scritto che loro sono imbarcarmi
nella modalità fantasma c'è scritto il
nonno e la nonna sono in vacanza ve
l'immaginate in bikini spiagge non la
nonna sono in vacanza slam brino e qui
no dai
ridiamo in modalità fantasma vero che
anche lei è andata in vacanza con il
luogo e modalità pratica l'indie magari
c'è anche la ndrina speriamo di no per a
dire perché mi fa venire un impatto di
natale saremo meglio la sanità esatto ok
aperto anche questa porta allora quindi
se non sbaglio c'era non so bene mondo
cazzo lanzi anche se so che il nonno e
la nonna solo in vacanza tanto celebrata
ruba non si può stare tranquilli un
momento allora in questi cassetti non
c'è niente proviamo ad aprire questa
porta allora questa porta porta fuori
casta porta prima non l'abbiamo aperta
che cos'è questo direi che non c'è
niente affatto fine proprio nascoste
queste chiavi c'è questo stiamo forse no
la ndrina ci metti paura
metti la briga questa porta è chiusa
forse qua dentro allora la chiave samp
ci sono due porte
allora questo abbiamo visto lo scarico
che funziona e ci mettiamo e qui se
questa prima non c'era la chiave ten del
del magazzino là fuori che può vedere
veder che sia fuori nel magazzino di
almeno vediamo qualcosa di nuovo
se questo è un generatore non puoi
attivare mare il generatore ancora serve
apprendo elettricità immagino quindi
toni hanno metile lover perché è già
buio
questo è un pezzo di d'aosta si serve
per dire arrende continuiamo ad
esplorare tia non si troviamo in qualche
altra chiave questa lasciamo qui per il
momento diamo continuiamo ad esplorare
la casa allora qui siamo passati salimmo
sopra da questa parte e anno c'era
un'altra porta da aprire qui se non
sbaglio per si è normale penso proprio
la sala da pranzo da pranzo
non mi va non si fa prendere un colpo
sulla linea ma questo è lo stesso
corridoio sembra una porta nascosta quel
vicino pensa che sia quella del
territorio sia quella d'accordo
ma qualche lo confesso mi soffitto amore
a salire spesso andiamo andiamo la
soffitta papa barbara mi trovavo rosa
adoro allora qui si è paurosa ci sono
solo tre anni spero di no avremo queste
porte dice qui è questo un computer non
esce mai si toglie maledetta per un pelo
non c'è niente questi cassetti che li
mettono fare sono un mafioso non
nascondo niente
tra l'altro queste scale hanno una certa
somiglianza con le nostre scale che
portano alla sufficiente se credi pure
lì e siamo fuori siamo tipo fuori dalla
casa ma c'è qualcosa c'è qualcosa del
con cisco prenderlo però devo uscire
fuori al momento non cadere giù o no
come faccio cadere bene a un pezzo di
legno davvero molto giugno magari ci può
servire sempre ottimo qualcosa di volta
interessante invece un pezzo di legno
anno potremmo anche salire sul tetto
diamo che cosa hai a qui c'è un
ascensore di putin e di misteri questa
carta cento se proprio questo bottone
non c'è elettricità che bisogna attivare
litri si terra in quello vero la banda
degli atleti tratti fare l'ascensore
così uno si può muovere liberamente cosa
stai su una ruota riusciremo a passare
lì ma forse qui e ci serve quel pezzo di
legno che abbiamo preso che fuori a
questa è la culla di chi è la culla dove
mettere gli stand 39 bird non figlio e
lo sa che ho tanti ricordi la storia va
mettere l'orsacchiotto
sì penso a pescara perché bussola tulle
si è agitato tutto ok abbiamo preso il
pezzo di legno ora dovremo riuscire a
passare in quel buco e prendere quello
c'è quindi dobbiamo salire sopra uscire
dal sopra il tetto e andare in quella
stanza linee per poter prendere
quell'oggetto si no
pensavo fosse sulle ndrine invece una
colonna allora adesso sappiamo sul tetto
e così i rientri a 1 in buca del tetto
richiamo se funziona il nostro piano
speriamo di sì ma forse non è qui che va
ho provveduto detto no sono caduto dal
tetto però ho scoperto che c'è qualcosa
in macchina si che cosa avete visto
c'era qualcosa che sberluccicante
macchina forse troviamo finalmente
legnano vediamo che cosa c'è in macchina
ho visto qualcosa che per luccicavano si
apre questa macchina con loro sei tu di
flint riina sì sì andiamo a metterlo
così almeno non è tantissimo però molto
piacere imprese si arrabbia tantissimo
pensa ci lascerà tranquilli è vero ok
proviamoci
quindi lo metti nella culla si ricordino
vero avrò paura scacco
per il pranzo eccoci qua ovviamente
spleen drina ha ripreso suo figlio norma
detto che torniamo questa fu libretti
voglio prendere questo asse di legno
anche prima non siamo riusciti però se
fossimo riusciti a mettere becco
l'orsetto adesso adesso che troviamo la
stanza lo mettiamo allora da lilly poi
rimane nella culla sechi vero non
dovrebbe messo qui si è messo forse devi
riprenderlo e mi dice di no non me lo fa
riprendere e allora proprio a stare
siamo qui a uomo perfetto capitano
quindi adesso possiamo prendere questo
che l'ingranaggio quindi abbiamo siamo
riusciti a prendere anche questa qui
piano piano
adesso però ho visto che abbiamo l'orso
proviamo a cercare la stanza miliardo
dove era vero però che grida esserci in
palio ai veri modalità pratica avremmo
forse questo qui ci serve né nel
giardino permettere l'elettricità nelle
campagne di megafono delle frasi forse
così se questi attrezzi esiste ma nella
campagna degli atei bene questo era
grain di tre se volete che continuiamo
aimi e scopriamo tutti i segreti mister
era stato un bel minaccia che voto gli
diamo finora io gli do un 10 perché
bellissima favola 09 perché usa entrino
anno fa venire il faro gates
e poi che voglio girare linate
lasciatecelo c'è scritto giorno dei
commenti
e ora viene ha saputo a quattro case
linee su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video caso quella che
preferite
buona visione ciao